[Música]
gracias por estar con nosotros
comenzamos reporteros
mucho se habla de los síntomas que
persisten durante meses luego de padecer
kobe 19 y aunque la mayoría se recupera
en unas semanas algunos se quedan con
varios padecimientos dolores de cabeza
fatiga extrema y dolores corporales lo
llaman ecovidi largo o síndrome post
hobbit y puede afectar no sólo a los
pulmones también al corazón y al cerebro
para muchos ha sido una batalla
demostrar que siguen enfermos y ahora
este fenómeno se direcciona a ser un
problema de salud pública un equipo de
nuestros reporteros en francia visitó a
varias personas con kobe largo para
tratar de entender qué es lo que pasa
mientras que los científicos franceses
buscan financiación para comenzar las
investigaciones
[Música]
sí
valor florent a ha sido tres veces
campeones de karate de europa pero hoy
su entrenamiento ha cambiado
radicalmente
es liviano
no es un ejercicio cardiovascular en
absoluto pero siento un salto en el
ritmo cardíaco no es muy agradable sobre
todo porque lo tengo desde hace algún
tiempo estamos walker como nada
hace unos meses fue cuando se contagió
de kobe 19
una forma leve al principio pero con
síntomas que persisten durante meses
[Aplausos]
[Música]
significa renunciar a dos años de
competición en los juegos olímpicos
presenciar a un posible cuarto título de
campeona de europa renunciar a los
juegos son los primeros y los últimos
para el kárate y el campeonato del mundo
que era la competición en la que quería
terminar mi carrera en dubai a la
fernández web
afectada por una miocarditis una secuela
cardíaca común entre los pacientes con
kobe largo la atleta de 29 años no tuvo
más remedio que poner fin a su carrera
deportiva
en comparación con lo que hacía antes es
tratar de mantenerse en forma de volver
a estar en forma si hablamos de secuelas
las secuelas que tengo del cobi no son
la pérdida de mi condición física
una de las muchas secuelas los síntomas
del cómic largo son muy variados y a
menudo muy incapacitante lado ms calcula
que una de cada diez personas que han
contraído el cómic 19 está afectada
y este es un kimono que se creó para los
juegos olímpicos con rayas rojas y
azules un poco más fino todavía con el
signo de francia pero no los habría
llevado mucho tiempo salieron el año
pasado
la karateca tuvo que pasar del todo a
los libros de texto ahora está haciendo
un máster en gestión
bueno
tengo que empezar una segunda vida estoy
en plena fase de transmisión que no es
tan sencilla en sí misma porque tengo
que plantearme nuevos retos
[Música]
estos cambios también afectan a los
niños y adolescentes
en febrero de 2020 toda la familia
peters contrajo cobit 19 16 meses
después nadie se ha recuperado
[Música]
para miley fue una pérdida de peso de 17
kilos con una hospitalización de casi 3
meses
manuel más incapacitado sigue teniendo
algunos síntomas
pero lo más incapacitante es su
hipersomnia y su niebla mental para mí
va a ser la fatiga del esfuerzo
flandes si nunca ha estado enfermo y va
al médico muy pocas veces porque
realmente no lo necesitaban era la más
sana de la familia
para preservar sus fuerzas en los
médicos le prohíben salir a pasear
cómo te sientes
estoy bien no estás demasiado cansado
en este momento no estás bien por ahora
[Aplausos]
juntos hacíamos mucho deporte todos los
jueves de semana ciclismo senderismo en
las montañas éramos una familia muy
deportiva la actividad era muy
importante para nosotros
salimos a pasear de vez en cuando pero
nunca durante mucho tiempo diez o quince
minutos no podemos hacerlo todos los
días y eso es que todo lo que podemos
hacer me quedo sin aliento rápidamente
y la fatiga dura varios días o incluso
semanas
duermes todo el día
[Música]
y me temo que no podré volver a la vida
de antes
[Música]
durante 14 veces no pude ocuparme de la
casa en absoluto no podía cocinar si
quería preparar la comida la preparaba
durante 5 minutos volvía a la cama
durante media hora y volvía a cocinar
durante 5 minutos los niños tuvieron que
ayudarme mucho bien me dibujó tu mano a
alternar la modalidad presencial
adaptada en el colegio con licencias
completas por enfermedad
hoy su profesora de inglés viaja para su
lección semanal en casa es complicado ya
que manu a está enfermo
limón
wake up in the moon
h
al watán se ven en noáin
[Aplausos]
la concentración estaba bien
pero si hacemos día tras día sin
descanso
estaré menos concentrado
[Música]
en
la fatiga intensa y la falta de
concentración son síntomas muy comunes
del cobi pediátrico de larga duración
manoa duerme a veces hasta 21 horas al
día
por ejemplo en matemáticas me cuesta más
visualizar en mi cabeza los cálculos
tengo que contar con los dedos que es lo
que más extrañas
los amigos
realmente no puedo trabajar es algo que
me preocupa
estoy sola con mis hijos es muy
angustioso y no saber cómo vas a pagar
las facturas dentro de seis meses o cómo
van a ir las cosas
estos temores se ven reforzados por la
falta de atención médica
todavía hay muchos médicos que piensan
que es totalmente psicológico tengo una
sensación de rabia de no ser escuchada
por la comunidad médica pero que cambió
un poco para los adultos creo que para
los niños no cambia nada a los médicos
les suelen compartir los últimos
estudios que acaban de publicar si
se les dan documentos enlaces a
determinados estudios y por eso también
nos sentimos abandonados porque sabemos
un poco más que los médicos
tras varios meses sin un diagnóstico fue
la profesora salmon cerón quien confirmó
a karim que efectivamente se trataba de
ccoo bit largo la infectóloga ha abierto
una de las pocas consultas dedicadas en
francia
muchos de mis colegas no creían en un
hobbit largo incluso pensaban que nos
estábamos inventando una patología 'el
hobbit' largo era como todos los
síndromes de fatiga crónica post
inducción y ahora hemos demostrado que
realmente en cierto número de casos no
despreciable el virus de hecho puede
persistir
y mientras la infectóloga lucha por
encontrar financiación para sus estudios
en francia los británicos recurren a su
experiencia
los británicos me han pedido que formen
parte del comité de expertos que
distribuye los 20 millones de euros para
el coach claro los franceses están
invitados a formar parte de estos
comités esto significa que se nos
reconoce por las publicaciones que hemos
hecho y cuando proponemos proyectos como
son
en francia la dotación para la
investigación sobre el commit largo es
de sólo 22 millones de euros casi 10
veces menos que la de los vecinos
británicos
[Música]
fondos que podrían utilizarse para
comprender las múltiples formas de la
enfermedad
es el caso del co victims un síndrome
violento que ha afectado a unos 600
niños en francia en este pequeño pueblo
del sur de francia ha comenzado la
batalla por el reconocimiento
estaba realmente cansada del hospital
quería volver a ver a mi familia
el tema tiene siete años la enfermedad
está con sus órganos vitales y la envió
a cuidados intensivos hoy la niña está
en remisión ahora casi he vuelto a la
normalidad bueno casi no del todo
vaya
para tráfico
todavía me quedan algunas secuelas
me duelen un poco las piernas caminar 10
minutos me duele tengo que subirme a la
silla de ruedas no me gusta y me
gustaría que todo volviera a ser como
antes
cuando me recupere de una gran fiesta
para amar y la madre de la conciencia
sobre esta enfermedad poco conocida que
comienza aproximadamente un mes después
del contagio por kobe se ha convertido
en una prioridad
en 100 700 correos electrónicos a
senadores y diputados y recibe 10
respuestas un poco decepcionante creo
porque si le ocurriera a su hijo sea
personal es
el co victims puede ser mortal para el
niño si no se diagnostica a tiempo por
otra parte una vez empezados los
tratamientos son bastante eficaces
existe una falta de conocimiento de kobe
y ms entre el personal de salud
si esa hubiera sido tratada a tiempo con
corticoides y
antiglobalizador y ha tenido que pasar
por la uci o habría sido poco tiempo y
seguramente no tendría las secuelas que
tiene hoy con una recaída cardiaca
también
en abril mari decidió crear la
asociación familia de los niños víctimas
del cob it pins
me hizo sentir útil en todo esto el
hecho de que nos reunamos nos apoyemos
seamos un grupo ese apoyo crea una unión
maravillosa
ya que si usted me da de ellos aceite
esencial como al día siguiente por
primera vez mari y emma se encuentran
con un diputado
siento nervios no te preocupes es muy
agradable la propia patricia mira y
lleva mucho tiempo padeciendo cobit
largo
he venido sólo por esta princesa hola
todo bien
si hola ustedes mari si tienes una mama
súper sic
la mamá y tu mamá escribió para que
leyera lo que te pasó
y pensé que no es posible que se permita
que los niños sufran tanto como los
adultos de sant fost sufrí realmente me
molesto por eso quería estar aquí hoy
porque creo que eres una niña muy muy
fuerte
y este testimonio es importante para
todas las demás personas que piensan que
el objetivo de la reunión para madrid es
mejorar el seguimiento médico de los
comités pins y los comités largos
pediátricos
es una cita por aquí y otra por allá no
hay ningún seguimiento entre los médicos
generales los cardiólogos los padres
solicitan las pruebas son ellos los que
tienen que pedir las pruebas para sus
hijos
le pedí al director del aire s que
creara la misma unidad pero para niños
tenemos que avanzar para que la gente
solo tenga que ir una vez hacerla
diagnóstico
desde esta grabación maría ha tenido una
reunión con la superintendencia de la
salud
ahora participa con el grupo de trabajo
kobe ping
manu ha hecho un nuevo amigo que tiene
cobit pediátrico largo sus exámenes
fueron revisados por un especialista que
pudo confirmar el origen cerebral de sus
síntomas la familia finalmente recibe un
diagnóstico
hoy por supuesto dejé mi carrera pero
hay una cosa que es más importante que
el deporte y es la salud
[Música]
en cuanto a valor flor en tanto tras
naufragar continúa su reconstrucción
[Música]
gracias por acompañarnos en esta emisión
de reporteros una vez más les recordamos
que pueden ingresar a nuestra página web
france24 puntocom para ver esta emisión
y las anteriores hasta la próxima semana
[Música]